bonne ou mauvaise idée benoît autour de
la table tea party clos ouais ouais vous
avez entendu chef sas et voilà ça c'est
une info moi aussi très bonne idée
[Rires]
d'aller le ventre le nom cyrill et aie
aie aie moi c'est moi c'est moi un menu
jeudi ayem fait moins bonne idée ou
c'est ce soit pour être mise à la haye
est mal à beaucoup de talent je pense
qu'elle aime c'est ça c'est une numéro
un ça veut dire que nous les deux des
numéros 14 plusieurs années que je veux
je pense qu'il sait excellent chez nous
donc c'est fait on pas que c'est fait ou
pas non non on est entre nous alors il
faut plus que les téléspectateurs soient
d'accord
bah vous allez gérer ça en vous lundi
que c'est mieux je finis les missions
bien géré ça l'a dit mais vous savez que
les téléspectateurs qui décident
est ce que vous voulez un petit sourire
il on a fait un sondage bonne ou
mauvaise idée pour eux alizée
124 46 voile à venise et à cinq ans de
nivea 53% et ben voila merci
[Applaudissements]
l'info l'info bon point quand le chef a
parlé bon bah on passe à tous
j'ai reçu un message de benoit et je
voudrais vous lire si c'est possible
il m'a écrit et c'est très touchant je
trouve ce qui se passe ça me regarde
juste ce que je peux te dire de plus
sincère c'est que jeudi à 16h j'ai
exactement la sensation d'arriver chez
mon mec est que mes affaires étaient
devant la porte alors que je laime
encore tout tout ce qui m'importe c'est
de retrouver emilie et mamad boxe je
voulais au moins finir ma saison 3
emilie ouais donc c'est ça collaborent
saison c'est douloureux commun